You mess with time it tends to mess back
you'll see
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new avengers marvel
video
marvel just announced a whole bunch of
schedule changes for marvel phase 4 so
we'll break it down and explain what it
means
they shuffled a bunch of different
things so now the movies are coming out
in a different order
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new disney plus giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know
which marvel phase 4 movie you're most
hyped up about but just starting with
the big stuff first
right after marvel released the Wandavision trailer just a couple days ago
and revealed that it would be airing
episodes by the end of the year everyone
got really pumped up yay finally some
new marvel content
they quickly followed up yesterday by
announcing that they were delaying the
black widow movie officially to next
year in 2021
see what they did there they tried to
butter you up before they give you the
bad news
and it's not just a minor delay the new
release date for the black widow movie
is may
7th next year cue the thanos scarlet
witch meme
you took everything from me
i don't even know who you are seriously
it's crazy i'll explain why they did
that
in a second that's a crazy delay but on
top of that because they gave that may
release date next year to the black
widow movie
it also meant they had to delay the
eternals movie in the shang chin the
legend of the 10 rings movie to later
next year it's not all bad news though
everyone looking at spider-man 3 someone
check on peter parker spider-man and
make sure that he's okay
protect spider-man from all these movie
delays so the good news is that right
now the only movies that marvel has
delayed during marvel phase 4
are those three that i just mentioned
black widow eternals in the shang chi
movie
every other marvel phase 4 movie is
still coming out
at least right now when they said it
would a little while ago including
spider-man 3
venom 2 the morbius movie technically
marvel movies but some of those are core
mcu movies and some are just connected
to the mcu movies by
spider-man looking at you sony
spider-verse so number four the obvious
question that you're all asking is why
did marvel do this they just hit a grand
slam with that Wandavision trailer they
actually reported that it got almost as
many views on all their social media
platforms as an avengers movie trailer
so everyone is crazy excited about
wandavision
turns out if you deprive people of new
marvel content for an entire year
they'll be a little bit excited when you
actually do release some new content
but the main reason why marvel decided
not to release the black widow movie in
november like it said it would earlier
this year was because of a little disney
movie
called mulan and also tenon so you
probably see where i'm going with this
if you haven't been following the news
disney conducted a big
grand experiment with the mulan movie a
little while ago they released it on
disney plus through a special pay tier
called disney premier access
before they released it in movie
theaters where you could pay an extra 30
on top of your regular disney plus
subscription fee to get the movie
before they actually dropped it in
theaters there were some countries and
places around the world where they did
release it in theaters where
theaters were open but there's still a
lot of big cities where you can't
actually go see a movie in a theater yet
it got all kinds of news from the press
but apparently based on disney's
behavior with the marvel black widow
movie
they probably were not totally happy
with the combined
mulan disney plus earnings in the box
office performance
it did terribly in china where they were
hoping that it would be a banger
turns out not so much i didn't bother to
do a mulan movie review just because i
felt like most of
my subscribers probably wouldn't be
paying to see the movie on disney plus
so there wasn't much of a point in me
posting a video about it
but on top of the debacle with the mulan
movie just a little while ago
all the other movie studios in hollywood
were looking at warner brothers and
christopher nolan's tenant movie
which had been in theaters for a while
now and it has also been
bombing because as you could guess no
one is going to theaters right now
also most theaters are limited capacity
to 25
later this year they'll open that up a
little bit more but even then
were theaters to sell out their maximum
occupancy limits all the big movies in
october and november would still
probably bomb so marvel and disney are
like if that we want our money back on
this 150 million dollar movie and
because of a lot of contractual issues
with theater owners around the world
they're almost forced to release it in
theaters in some way
so they just decided the best option
would be to delay the black window movie
to next year on the hopes that most
people would actually be going to
theaters by then
but why may and not february because
there's a lot of movies that were
supposed to come out in february next
year
the eternals movie was originally coming
out then right after the black widow
movie
disney and marvel probably pushed black
widow to may just assuming that things
would still be
bad in february so it's kind of a
pessimistic but realistic take on their
part
so then number three that created a
domino effect making them delay the
eternals movie to the end of next year
in shang qi to summer in july why did
they rearrange
shang chi in the eternals though
originally eternals was supposed to come
out before shang chi in the legend of
the ten rings
we all know that marvel movies have to
come out in a certain order because the
way all the post credit scenes and
overarching
infinity saga style stories connect with
each other
they're doing the same thing that they
did with the marvel phase one movies
connecting them all with this big
overarching story
leading up to the next big avengers 5
story but based on what they just did i
think we can all assume that there's
nothing in the shang chi
movie post-credits scene that spoils the
eternals movie so changing the order of
those wouldn't mess anything up
and also certain types of movies certain
genres
make more money at different points in
the year for instance traditional big
action movies tend to do better during
the summer months
that's why black widow in the shang chi
movie are summer movies
you already know what's going on with
the black widow movie we've seen a bunch
of trailers but the shang chi movie is
kind of like marvel's version of bruce
lee's enter the dragon
the actor who plays shang chi even
described his character
as being like marvel's bruce lee so huge
kung fu action movie i'm sure it's going to
be awesome there'll be a bunch of iron
man easter eggs because the mandarin the
main villain of that movie
is a core iron man villain the whole
concept of the 10 rings organization
and the 10 rings of power also showed up
throughout the iron man movies
the reason why the eternals movie is
coming out in november is because
originally if you don't remember
it's been 84 years since they announced
their original marvel phase 4
schedule at comic con that movie was
originally supposed to come out november
before the first big movie delays so
they'd already planned for it to be an
end of the year kind of movie
and it's a big cosmic mythology heavy
movie like the thor movies and they
mostly release the thor movies in
november
i know there's been a lot of questions
about how the thor stuff will connect to
the eternals because
as guardians are so long lived like if
odin has been alive for tens of
thousands of years
the answer to that is probably yes he
probably knew all about them
but number two on top of those movies
getting new schedules they've also
changed the release order for the
avengers disney plus shows that are all
supposed to cross over with the marvel
phase 4 movies
Wandavision is just the beginning of
that later this year originally falcone
winter soldier was supposed to release
episodes starting in august
obviously that's come and gone now it
would have been the first big marvel
disney plus show
then they would have done the Wandavision episodes now the reason that
Wandavision is coming first is just
mostly because there are spoilers for
the black widow movie ending
in falcon and winter soldier it just
trades heavily on stuff that they set up
during the black widow movie
falcon is picking up the shield from
captain america so obviously that takes
place after avengers end game
black widow takes place in the past
between captain america civil war and
avengers infinity war
so the main reason why falcon and winter
soldier probably spoil stuff in the
black widow movie is because of what
they're setting up in the movie
early prediction is that that's based on
the other thunderbolts and weapons plus
easter eggs and casting announcements
the best theory is that thunderbolt ross
will just have some sort of black widow
post credit scene where he has a very
nick fury iron man
post-credit style scene where he appears
and teases that he's setting up a new
team quote-unquote and that team will
just wind up being the thunderbolts in
present day
after avengers end game i'm here to talk
to you about the avenger initiative
samuel l jackson has also teased that
he's going to be doing the same thing
from that
sword space station but that won't play
out till a little bit later in marvel
phase four
but number one i know you're all asking
2020 has been such a crap year what's
going to happen for the next couple of
months before we finally make it to 2021
so next month the bright ray of hope is
that disney plus will start releasing
the star wars mandalorian season two
episodes
that'll be eight episodes total then
they'll start airing the avengers
Wandavision episodes
originally that was only going to be six
episodes for a mini-series but there
have been reports that they may have
added extra Wandavision episodes which
would be great
marvel probably won't reveal all those
details till the next month or two
they'll probably use the mandalorian
season two to start promoting
Wandavision more so that's when we'll
start seeing more trailers for that
but because of these couple marvel
movies that they just delayed we
probably won't see the first marvel
eternals trailer
until next year but they might release
the shang chi movie
trailer before the end of the year big
takeaway is that it's not quite as bad
as it sounds there's going to be
so many marvel movies and comic book
movies next year so hopefully that will
make up for the crap year that we've had
during 2020
but if you have any big questions about
what's going on with the marvel movies
or the disney plus series just post them
in the comments
click here for my new Wandavision
trailer video in avengers easter eggs
and click here for that new ghostwriter
marvel hellstrom trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe this is the way!